I was talking to Elisa the other day
about this and I said is everybody a
republican she said it to me she goes is
everybody secretly a republican because
you all kind of look around and you say
I don't know there are a lot of people
who you know who will kind of wink and
say hey Michael keep up the good work
and say hey I secretly voted for Trump
or hey this that or the other thing but
the culture makes you think that
everyone is trans everyone is woke
everyone supports PLM but light now is
putting transvestites on their cans so
what's going on it's that the
the people who have the biggest
microphones the people who control the
liberal establishment they're very very
vocal but there is a bubbling up it's
not just a fantasy to say that
conservatives have a silent majority I
don't know if we have a silent majority
we certainly have a silent plurality
though we have a lot of people who have
become frustrated and some of them are
beginning to break and some people are
saying you know what I'm leaving this
party